the gloriously chilling adventures of
sabrina has arrived on netflix and a
devilishly dark take on the popular
teenage witch who so many loved watching
in a mid-1990s sitcom
yupikai movie lovers it's jan here and
today i'm diving into the 10 biggest
differences between chilling adventures
of sabrina and melissa joan heart
sabrina the teenage witch
keep watching to the end to find out the
riverdale cameo you won't want to miss
and if you're finding me for the first
time every week i do deep dives into
your favorite tv shows and movies
so tap the bell to stay up to date with
all my new videos
one of the highlights of the 90s sitcom
was sabrina's cat salem
the show brought the wisecracking kitty
to life using a mix of animatronic
puppets and real cats while his frequent
sarcastic comments were memorably voiced
by nick baquet
in the show salem was previously a
warlock but had been turned into a cat
to punish him for attempting to take
over the world
not that that stopped him from getting
up to all kinds of other mischief to
much comic effect in keeping with the
show's generally light tone
as for the chilling adventures of
sabrina if you were hoping for some
black cat backchat then you're out of
luck as this particular feline version
of salem never speaks
except to briefly introduce himself the
first time he turns up at her home but
that's when he's actually in his goblin
form
i heard
the new salem arrives after the
half-witch tries summoning a familiar
and despite not having the gift of the
gab he still gets an active part and
some cool scenes and is a rather
adorable presence
a non-verbal salem doesn't mean you'll
miss out on the kind of snark and
comedic dialogue you enjoyed in the 90s
show though
because another character takes on a
similar role sabrina's cousin ambrose is
a charming witty warlock who didn't
appear in the original sitcom but is
based on a character from the comics
with his tv backstory being given a
tweak from the chilling adventures of
sabrina books
like sitcom salem tv ambrose has been
punished for his part in a conspiracy
in ambrose's case he tried to blow up
the vatican in the new series ambrose
who's brilliantly played by chance
podomo is someone who sabrina often
turns to for advice and help as a
partner in crime in her various schemes
much like sitcom salem as for sabrina's
aunts hilda and zelda there's a similar
dynamic between the sisters the big
difference being that the 90s show has a
lighter fairy godmother style fluffier
version while the netflix series takes
things to a much darker devil worshiping
place
in sabrina the teenage witch zelda is
the intelligent science-minded logical
aunt while hilda tends to be less
practical and generally more fun-loving
and outgoing
they get up to stuff like making perfect
men out of dough
and turning themselves into teenagers so
they can keep their eye on their knees
at a gig without her knowing
in the chilling adventures zelda is
played by australian actress miranda
otto of lord of the rings fame and is
very much a no-nonsense witch and
certainly the much sterner of sabrina's
aunts
zelda's mid-atlantic accent and whole
manor positively oozes betty davis which
is funny because kianan shipka who plays
sabrina recently played betty davis's
daughter in the tv series feud
aunt hilda meanwhile has a british
accent and is a softer more openly
kind-hearted witch with a fun sense of
humor and generally less confidence than
her sister
she's played by lucy davis who you'll
doubtless recognize as wonder woman's
essa candy
the on-screen chemistry between miranda
otto and lucy davis is fantastic and
they take the bickering between the
aunts on the 90th show to a whole new
cane and abel level of darkness in the
first season of chilling adventures
we're told that brina's parents have
died in an accident
her mother was mortal and her father
edward was a progressive high priest in
the church of night
that's a huge difference from the
original 90s show where sabrina's
parents are both still alive though
they're divorced
in the sitcom sabrina's father lives in
her spell book where she sees him early
on in the first season though she does
later get to see him in real life too
as for sabrina's mortal mother well her
half-witch daughter isn't allowed to see
her as if she does her mother will turn
into a literal ball of wax and that's
something that did actually happen on
the show
when it comes to their tone and look
sabrina the teenage witch and the
chilling adventures of sabrina are
absolutely
poles apart sabrina the teenage witch
ran for seven
seasons from 1996 and was a brightly
coloured and lit
situation comedy it was full of goofy
storylines cartoony characters and zany
schemes with all sorts of weird and
wonderful magic goings on
including episodes that featured
sabrina's boyfriend turning into a frog
her seriously ott pancake addiction and
the time she almost had to marry a troll
things were generally kept bright and
breezy and didn't really have to make
sense over the seasons with characters
sometimes disappearing with no real
explanation like sabrina's best friend
jenny after season 1.
in comparison chilling adventures is
much more devilish
far darker and definitely more intense
and gory
season one of the slow burn show follows
sabrina's dark
education and really leans into its
horror origins with loads of easter eggs
and references to classic freight flicks
in some nice meta moments the netflix
show tips its hat to its
90s predecessor with zelda asking to be
saved from the melodramatics of a
teenage witch
and prudence noting that sabrina has
gone dark so overall
chunning adventures is more akin to
buffy the vampire slayer while sabrina
the teenage witch is more like the 60s
sitcom bewitched
now while the original live-action tv
show was set in westbridge boston
and had sabrina only discovering she was
a half witch on her 16th birthday
netflix's series is located in greendale
across the sweetwater river
from riverdale and sabrina knows she's a
half-witch half-mortal right from the
start
time-wise sabrina the teenage witch was
very much set in the era it was made the
mid-1990s onwards
but when it comes to the chilling
adventures of sabrina it's impossible to
pin down exactly when this new show is
set
that's because the series is a
deliberate mix of many different
eras so modern sensibilities and adult
themes are blended with costume
sets and props drawn from victorian
times to the 1960s 70s 80s and beyond
another big difference between the
netflix series and the mid-1990s show is
that over its seven season run sabrina
the teenage witch welcomed a huge number
of celebrities on setting cameos and
guest star roles
among the very many famous faces was a
pre-breaking bad brian cranston who
played a magical lawyer
mary poppins star dick van dyke who was
an old friend of salem's
actress racquel welsh who was sabrina's
aunt vesta magicians penn teller who
played the head of the witch's council
and his assistant
and a ton of music stars including
britney spears coolio the backstreet
boys and usher who played a love doctor
but what this season of chilling
adventures of sabrina does have is a
riverdale cameo look out for ms wardwell
ordering a pizza
because when the delivery boy arrives he
turns out to be riverdale's ben button
this isn't ben's first time in greendale
as he had music lessons and hookups at
miss grundy's home there
but spoiler ahead for episode 2 season 3
of riverdale
ben jumped out of a hospital window
after telling betty and jughead that he
was following the gargoyle king's plan
so what are your theories about how ben
turned up in the new sabrina show and
which other riverdale characters would
you like to see appear
in season two now i'd love to know if
you're a fan of the original sabrina
sitcom and what did you think of the new
show
let's continue the conversation in the
comments below and you can also follow
me on twitter
if you enjoyed this i really appreciate
a thumbs up and a share thanks for
watching and see you next time yippie
kay movie lovers